it seems that grief and tragedy have  followed you since birth cruel fate  dark plan has taught you to the corners  of the earth you've brushed with death a  thousand times yet still you have your  life it is your fate to save this world  for this you must survive bright  luminary let the light shine on the  world again  [Music]  fate hangs by a thread you must fight  fire become steel all that matters is  power and the only power that matters is  that of the darkness  it's time to play  right  you can save on one that's Annie beckons  [Music]  this is where my story  [Music]  do not lose heart do not look back and  tell how times true  [Music]  both luminarie we swear to protect you  while we live none shall defeat you yep  we're all in this together  joys what you've got let's do this lead  on darling  [Music]